yoth 26 sud il ya pas mal de temps j'ai
posté une photo de moi quand j'étais
petit à noël en train de mener une ps2
et j'ai vu que ça vous avez carrément
plus récemment j'ai retrouvé plein de
remords quand j'étais petit je me suis
dit on va le supprimer
1 alors je me suis dit qu'on allait vous
regardez tous ensemble et je me suis pas
spoil pour avoir l'effet de surprise
avec vous c'est parti très bien moi qui
joue avec une sarbacane à boules et avec
un pull à peu près 10 points est trop
grand pour moi [ __ ] cette tête de
démon quoi j'aimerais autorise voiture
est ou plutôt je vais tous vous tuer ces
petits gars au delà du style ou pas tu
veux boire un verre avec moi si tu peux
pas je m'en bats les steaks hachés des
halles josé dias et peut-être à l'époque
[ __ ] je savais alors le cas déjà je
sais pas qui tu aimes billet ce jour là
mais c'est scandaleux tu aurais dû te
révolter et à le monsieur derrière la
bulle n'est pas content c'est où ça joue
ça va pulser boy george bush derrière
[ __ ] et bon jeu c'est peut-être ce qui
était lui aussi mais quelle est cette
photo à moteur ou pas oooh l'homme qui
aimait les bonbons déjà à l'époque
j'avais les dents plutôt blanche à cette
époque ça doit bien dater un commence a
pris car je suis fort avec pantalon
décathlon bon suivant skateurs ou pas
inscrite en herbe
là je fais un petit rail de micromètres
mes mains je suis où et comment elle me
regarde et alors les jalouse c'est quoi
cette tête mais je suis maquillée
brouillard
qu'est ce que je vais tenter la cecafa
augmenté en baston après avec elle à
chaud je n'avais pas la faire marcher
j'étais un peu jeune
il m'a volé mon pull de la première
photo lui a jeté vue [ __ ] j'avais le
style à un plus de style que maintenant
quand même c'est ça qui me fout mal
grâce à cette photo gp choplin de file
un vraiment à la maternelle j'étais un
peu le king ah oui on peut le faire mais
je devais avoir chaud qu à chaque photo
gd [ __ ] de paul erard a eu un gros
pull de ouf
regardez fait j'allais ce pull quoi
mischler bonjour c'est quoi ça c'est le
jeu de société je crois bien s était de
démons elle tu as vu il ya une mygale
là-bas à bon droit et vas-y voilà tout
chez murphy des chiens mais c'était un
peu la guerre entre mon frère et moi
cette époque qu'est ce qui est nouveau
en 2004
ah ben on peut voir que j'avais pris 2
cm c'est pas trop mal à mener d'un petit
short comme ça des t-shirts racaille on
les appelait mon frère on faisait des
gains de celui qui en avait de plus
voilà et il en avait le plus donc
j'étais un peu insoumis ont regardé cet
enfant et son papa regardez cet amour
ouais c'est incroyable et 7 passes ta
box en font what you're gonna do ba je
fais cette tête pour séduire les filles
aussi mais ça marchait pas aulas photo
denis est regardé comme chénier mais le
faux sourire oh quelle est belle alors
ça se met deux demi-soeurs avec mon
frère et moi même de mon frère salut
c'est de sortir avec moi
non non non moi à chaque fois que j'ai
une photo qui date autant je suis en
train de jouer et apparemment j'étais
déjà très nul à l'époque aux jeux vidéo
ou la tête que je tiens aux
équilibristes ou pas équilibriste ou pas
ce jour là que j'ai appris à faire ça et
je crois que je peux viser mieux qu'à
l'heure actuelle c'est bon rien n'est
cassé tout va bien de me situer voilà je
chasse appelé gizmo il est écroué il
était adorable méga keller c'est chaque
pluie tout en décalages tout en outre at
elle pointé la frontière mois plus tard
donc là je passe le permis voiture après
permis moto est ce le départ et tu as vu
que j'assure à de chuck zachary voyez
vous ai pas menti c'est je crois qu'ils
vont dessau au ski voilà vingt magasins
qui vendent évident sur trec cahiers et
non à acheter plein voilà pourtant
n'était pas du tout des racailles je
pense que ça se voit notamment sur celui
de photos aucune racaille présente aux
mollahs ça partait un peu en steak à ces
accidents et ses accidents mon frère me
rentrer dedans ou alors ils voulaient
m'aider je pense plutôt qu'il venait
m'aider
voilà si je finis comme ça c'est qu'il
m'avait aidé et c'est l'heure du bowling
away
attention il s'apprête à tirer il tire
avec une tête de vicieux il reprend une
boule et c'est la fin on peut voir mon
frère en train d'essayer sur cette photo
il allait pas très bien s'il vous plaît
admettez le tous tous les garçons
derrière cette vidéo quand vous étiez
petit vous aviez cette coupe ne mentez
pas je le sais la coupe universel de
l'enfant par contre vous n'aviez pas
cette coupe une flore homme qui avait de
suite
enfin elle cherchait une coupe de
cheveux un peu plus stylée que la
fameuse houppette là il était parti sur
un délire un peu bizarre mais après ce
petit état elle a trouvé une coupe
vraiment viable et cool
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je suis là
avec un chevreuil dans la bouche en
train de faire l'amour est avec une
fille qui déprime je préfère zapper
cette photo tout de suite c'est l'heure
du ping pong ah ah c'est déjà fini
voilà apprécié la boisson non mais c'est
quoi c'est peut-être moi qui boit comme
ça tu bois comme sa personne par
regarder cet amour pour son père c'est
beau à ta j'habite police est parfaite
qu à l'époque c'est pas photoshop et ça
c'est pas faute au chantier qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais je me demande en
hausse et un t-shirt racaille ou pas je
sais la question tout le monde se pose
pas je crois que c'est un tueur tracas
sûr que d'être une racaille c'était une
sorte de squelette des maniaques au pire
on s'en fout un bon je reproduis bien
mais guémas de l'époque ah non ça
c'était pas ma ps2 par contre je crois à
moins que aussi c'était ma ps2 qui
regardent et cette joie sur le visage de
gros plans de nolife
hop là je me souviens je me disais tu as
pas puisque c'est ça est ce que c'est ce
à quoi je pense papa et mon père il
était là je sais pas fiston peut-être
peut-être
et là je découvre que c'est la ps2 wii
voilà et puis on passa de la gymnastique
j'ai fait à trois on dit quand j'étais
petit j'étais pas mauvais je t'ai pas
mauvais je veux dire j'ai mis tes bien
les animaux et ou quoi c'est pas mal
rien que mon coach me regarde et jean
luc à tes jambes des bras [ __ ]
regardez un peu cette souplesse dans ce
petit essai troupe a dû regarder cette
hausse est incroyable la virilité
voilà c'était mes années de gymnastique
et du coup j'étais et ben pas sur le
podium
c'est l'heure du gâteau ouais ouais la
ps2 à j'ai eu à noël je savais pas
j'ouvre du champomy assez bon cadeau
qu'est ce que c'était or regardez quand
je vous dis que j'étais le faire tandis
qu'à l'époque si génial quand un voleur
logitech pour jouer à gran turismo sur
ps2 à voile à l'âge le test jamais l'air
d'aimer ça franchement j'étais content
c'est quoi ça c'est une sorte de
mutation game boy avec des jeux un peu
rigolo savez jamais que des cadeaux
comme ça quoi
ouais métier nogent kevin kikoo du 78
temps forts je t'aime sort avec moi lol
j'ai des lunettes avec le linge derrière
cette photo mérite d'être encadré fera
c'est incroyable du coup j'ai peur pour
la suivante
non donc je refuse oh c'est la fin a été
puissante c'est là donc la sémer 11 ans
avec mon corps de foetus mais j'étais
avec mon papa et mon frère a le tee
shirt et l'incroyable picole mannequin
est ce que c'est que ses cheveux
aulas lors les chevaux lourds c'est une
catastrophe ah non mais ça va pas du
tout mais je ne savais pas que je peux
avoir une foule figureront sans déconner
mais regardez-moi ça mais si j'ai aussi
poussé jeu peuple un truc comme ça ils
s'étaient tous en arrière comme un
acteur plage illhousiens voilà leurs
deux jours à kate ou bien une scène d'un
film un peu style et ou alors qu'en fait
c'est plutôt stylée et on joue c'est
l'heure du pipi dans l'eau arrêté chez
moulia à l'appui en photo j'arrive pas à
la faire celle là ouais mais c'est parce
que j'ai pas les cheveux longs donc
forcément regarder quoi ça me faisait
une petite queue de cheval une toute
petite mini queue de cheval une mignonne
queue de cheval et voilà j'en sais tout
pour les photos j'espère qu'il vous aura
fait marrer j'ai une dernière petite
surprise pour vous qui n'est pas des
moindres
je vous interdit de rire sinon je me
vexe donc cette vidéo motion vacances à
la piscine et je demande à la mère de
filmer quelque chose et ça se passe pas
trop comme prévu je vous laisse regarder
la bonne grosse voix de héguy c'est quoi
sa grand mère attendait moonwalk n'était
pas si d'hélios a déjà dans un premier
temps pour la défense pour garder
ça va bon après la coupe coupe
mais j'ai un petit bruit de mcci qui
sait qu'il a fait un truc de merde quoi
sur des coudes bien le mec qui lâche 2,4
à chaud parce que j'ai refait nombreux
alors pas cette fois là bas j'en ai
partout et des classes et attend
maintenant tu ne pouvais pas être puniet
ce que ça a super fille là où on allait
l'arrêter me péter les coûts et sa vidéo
ouais moi même jour c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur cette photo et vidéo qui
donne pas mal juste la chose aurait pu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ça fait vraiment plaisir et ça fera
plaisir à mon mois de quand j'étais
petit et que j'avais 11 ans je dis
absolument n'importe quoi j'avais envie
de partager ça avec vous parce que je
trouve que c'est toujours des trucs
marrants à regarder surtout qu'on s'en
souvient plus et qu'on se demande ce
qu'on foute est déjà à l'époque et on
peut voir point j'étais déjà un sacré
combat on peut le dire on se retrouve
très vite dans une nouvelle vidéo merci
de plus en plus on doit me suis même
pendant les vacances ça fait vraiment
plaisir et peut sans trace de la vidéo
je répète que tout le monde
et pis un voilà j'aimerais avoir les
cheveux longs comme quand j'étais petit
avoir une queue de cheval mignonne 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]